lucy hi
despite joining the show late sadie sync
has really been running up that hill to
become one of our favorite actors in
stranger things so we're taking a look
back at how she's grown over the course
of the show a lot of time spent in the
harness i guess number one growing up on
set you can expect a lot of your firsts
to happen there too sadie sings first
kiss happened on the show at the end of
season two she wasn't too keen on it so
the duffer brothers teased well now we
have to include a kiss truly they were
only teasing of course and sadie wasn't
perturbed saying she wouldn't have done
it if she didn't feel comfortable and
hey the nice thing about your first kiss
being with your friend is you'll never
cringe when you remember it like you
will if things didn't end so nicely with
your boyfriend i'm not mad at it
number two use the force max hitting
your head is a better option than facing
the wrath of max can we play this back
in slow motion maybe zoom in a little
this time beautiful
just
beautiful
number three we do not relish in the
thought of these characters ever growing
up you may recall the most terrifying
part of stranger things was the
condiment bottles my name's ketchup and
my name is mustang one thing's for sure
they're barbara cute together we catch
up in munster maybe they can get the
rest of the cast in on this how has
nobody asked the boys if they could be a
condiment which one they'd be who do you
think would play mayo finn noah and what
about hot sauce we think we'd leave that
to dager forget vacna the demogorgon
should have evolved into a hot dog for
season four's villain
number four and a hot dog demogorgon
would have been the perfect foil for
sadie sink who is a proud vegan she's an
animal lover through and through cast
your bets now is sadie sink a cat or a
dog person the answer is pretty apparent
she can be spotted playing with doggos
at every chance she gets and there are
oddly a lot of those chances on set this
is rocky she loves belly runs over her
last few years on the set sadie went
from being a vegetarian to fully vegan
this is sig it's short for sigourney and
she is a rescue dog
number five well vecna was definitely no
hot dog but the outfit was pretty real
sadie felt incredibly lucky to not have
to work with another cgi monster and
instead work with jamie campbell bauer
in a mostly practical vechna prosthetic
which kind of
made it easier for me so i'm not like
staring at a man in a green suit
she spent somewhere between four days to
a week in the lair the shoot was intense
got a little scraped up but it was
really really fun it definitely wasn't
as intense as it was for jamie though
for a 7 a.m shoot he'd be in at 1am to
get his prosthetics on we bet he's
jealous of sadie with her quick change
in the morning
number six the change takes a little bit
longer than a broadway quick change but
in the grand scheme of film it's fast
max is one of the lower maintenance
characters it only takes sadie 20
minutes to get ready for the day so hair
makeup and costume she takes less
maintenance for a tv show than we take
getting ready for work in the morning
unless you're working from home then
showers and pants are optional as
opposed to her co-star millie who takes
an hour when she needs to get that wig
on those 40 minutes of beauty sleep
really make a difference
number seven that feel when you're
having a power nap because your 20
minutes of getting your costume on in
the morning are exhausting and the boys
just wreck it one of sadie's favorite
moments from season 4 was
incredibly odd it was 5 30 in the
morning and she'd fallen asleep in her
chair
she woke up to the sounds of birds
chirping and the sun just beginning to
rise and it was just beautiful
but then she opened her eyes and there
were gayton and caleb eating a giant
chicken quesadilla at 5 30 in the
morning and she just thought it was the
most hilarious thing
[Applause]
number eight she's rising on up in the
world season four brought in a new stunt
for sadie sync like this is the most
elaborate form of harness harnessing
that i've ever done of course the
episode was a show stopper if you can
get past a few of the cheesier visual
effects in becnus lair sadie's
performance was fantastic i don't know
how many i think it might have been a
week that we spent on that or like four
days i guess the simplicity of her arc
and the downplayed feelings of the
character were perfection it's no wonder
the world has become obsessed with her
this season but her levitating stunt is
probably the biggest stunt she's ever
got to do in her short career she's
growing up so fast hard to believe she's
already 20. they gave her rehearsal time
which we imagine they do not give to the
more seasoned actors to simply float in
the air for a few seconds but there was
a whole element of choreography to it i
can lean back a little bit less
sort of
number nine the stranger things cast
actually spends more time apart than
together so sadie's pretty lucky she
gets to spend it with the funniest guy
in the cast it's been gaiton he's been
making me break character a lot recently
caleb also makes her crack up from time
to time but gayton takes the trophy for
season 4. sadie was also grateful that
the cast got shuffled around and some
unlikely pairings happened because it
meant she got to spend more time with
new people which she loves and she
really bonded with maya hawk who plays
robin is anybody else still stuck on
sadie's bemusement at the whole
quesadilla situation no just us okay
then
number 10 sometimes it really is the
little things that amuse dear sadie like
the 5 30 quesadilla popsicle day on the
set of season 4 was ridiculous as the
cast were enjoying a refreshing snack
the ants wanted to join them because you
had this idea we're like what if we made
a trail of popsicle juice did it work
who can say for sure somebody came over
and used some ant spray sadie thought
this was fascinating enough to capture a
photo of the first ad tudor holding out
the popsicle though yeah we can kind of
see why sadie's jealous of millie bobby
brown's social media game
number 11. imagine if your homework was
to do the one thing that scared the
pants off of you oh wait that sounds a
lot like school presentations well
sadie's homework was a bit different if
you recall she didn't join the cast
until season two of stranger things the
latest passenger to join us on our
curiosity voyage
maxine when it was already a massive hit
it's max and she was terrified to watch
the first season she hates horror movies
and had to keep turning down the volume
or covering her eyes she just couldn't
do it we wonder how she held up on set
was it all demystified or did she live
those darker moments in fear perhaps the
show is easier to watch now that she's
in it being fixated on her performance
might just be enough of a distraction
from those spooky scary things
number 12 we were a bit relieved when
the show brightened up in season three
as we imagined sadie was too the first
two seasons of stranger things were set
in the fall so the costumes were more
subdued and sadie's not a fall girl she
loves spring and summer fashion she
loves summer dresses she loves color so
she loved that they got to play with the
awesome 80s trends she just adored the
jazzercise studio with all the moms and
bright leggings and leg warmers sadie
sink seems hyper-fixated on the little
things but hey she plans on making the
most of every moment she's sad
she's tired not the best situation while
we're in awe of her performance we still
love the battle of star court it was
just so gorgeous how do you top that
what moment from stranger things took
your breath away be it the stunning
visuals or terrifying creatures let us
know in the comments and thanks for
hanging out with us here at the things